what would happen if tether went away is
it something where now tether has become
almost you know like it's too big to
fail I believe in the hyper reconization
so if the world will go towards uh uh
you know more and more adoption of
Bitcoin I think it's fine for tether to
decrease and and uh to to potentially
subtitle usdt to decrease in into a way
we are not that uh the type of guys and
saying well we have to do everything
that we can to make sure that uh you
know tether will be used in from year to
the next two thousand years that doesn't
make any sense for us right so if the
world doesn't need any more stable
current technology that's fine means
that the word is evolving uh the word is
to going towards other directions
all right guys bang bang Paulo I thought
a great place for us to start this
conversation is the rise of stable coins
obviously they used to be very small
almost non-existent uh now we have about
125 billion dollar market cap of which
tether is the largest stable coin can
you talk about the last couple of years
and from your perspective how important
stable coins popularity in crypto has
been
yeah sure so
um as I said you know
um the disabled coins had a little bit
of History
um that was funded nine years ago
actually the sixth of October
um uh tether I would um had his uh had
his uh ninth birthday and
um yeah the in the last few years though
uh the simple coins changed for from
being a product basically designed at
the beginning for cryptocurrency Traders
uh for helping moving
um Fiat across different uh um exchanges
to help arbit treasures and so on and
forth but with covet with the
um increased
um devaluation of national currencies
especially in emerging markets and
thinking about turkey and thinking about
um you know Argentina Venezuela and so
on
um stable coins more and more have been
demonstrated to be an asset that
considered a lifeline for communities
living in developing countries and
um the fact that uh you know the economy
suffered a bit hit with with the during
the pandemic the fact that uh you know
uh in inflation is going through the
roof more and more have and the the
crypto markets in general have been
um suffering as well as well as the the
internal financial markets people in
this moment wants um trying to find
um safety of trying to find stability in
their life they don't this is a period
in which uh speculation is not
um definitely the the first thought of
um
um of people right so they want
something that is predictable something
that you know they wake up in the
morning they know that they have the
same pretty much the same purchase and
value or power that than the day before
the week before if you think about the
Turkish lira the Turkish layout
evaluated around
um 80 percent in in the last 18 months
uh compared to the US dollar
and so
um if you are a Turkish person probably
you would prefer to keep your funds in
USB team pattern usdt rather than in
Turkish heras and so it has been
um an interesting shift
um also is uh I would say
when when tether created uh usdt we
couldn't not believe uh we couldn't not
think to all these use cases of course
the growth has been immense and you know
we are you know everything when I wake
up I'm still surprised about the the you
know the the growth of this space of
this industry
um yet it's I think I I like uh what
um the the the the real true purpose of
stable coins I like the fact that they
are now used by hundreds of millions of
people uh around the world to find uh
stability to find you know to to be used
as a way to transfer wealth to store
wealth and so on
and when you think about people in
whether it's turkey or other areas where
there's hyperinflation or a significant
devaluation I think the story for a long
time had been Bitcoin is uh the solution
right people are going to go and they're
going to buy Bitcoin we see that
happening to some degree there are
definitely people in these countries
that buy Bitcoin but it seems like also
a lot of people are buying stable coins
as well and the reason why I kind of
position it as if you're in a dire
financial position right your economy is
uh kind of wobbling your currency is
being devalued if you have an internet
connection you now have choice you can
choose from a couple of different
currencies and it does seem like people
are choosing stable coins and Bitcoin
does your expectation it will continue
to be stable coins in Bitcoin or do you
think that stable coins serve like a
really interesting uh kind of solution
for these individuals where maybe
Bitcoin isn't going to be used for
medium of exchange and only for store
value or how do you think of these two
Assets in their relationship to each
other
well I think the uh we cannot discount
the fact that uh
um stable coins are the majority the
stable coins and these 125 billion are
actually
um uh representing uh US dollar stable
coins right so if you think but there
are Europe euro-based stable coins
tatter has uh viewer tether that was
launched
um in 2018 2019 and the reality is that
I think the market copies is ridiculous
compared to
um to usdt the reason is that everyone
wants the dollar in this world so dollar
is the most established asset and is the
most everyone everyone knows it right so
if you talk to all the generations from
the youngest to the oldest they know
dollar they know gold actually uh the
second biggest table coin that that has
created is XLT is a stable coin that is
uh fully backed by gold but that is that
tells you that people you know are the
Euro was there has been there since the
last 20 30 years
um the dollar has much longer life gold
has uh you know 5 000 years of history
and so people tend to go to things that
they know that they are solid that have
been
um in in their families or you know
understood by their families uh for
generations and so you know with the the
dollar has still that uh sort of Mark of
um most ability and among all the
inflation all the devaluation of the the
different uh National currencies in the
end the dollar is the safest one among
all of them right so the dollar is the
biggest economy in the world and so
provides more Assurance to people that
have to that need to choose where to put
their savings
Bitcoin is
um is the newest of all the currencies
and uh we are seeing adoption right I'm
personally a bitcoiner and every time I
talk about tether I also try to talk
about Bitcoin because I think one of the
roles of stable coins is never forget
that if their role as
um for sure innovators but also their
their role as
um companies that should foster uh
Financial Freedom and Bitcoin is the
ultimate Financial Freedom right so but
it just takes more time for people to
understand it
younger Generations are more prepared to
that to this discussion to understand
the intrinsic value to understand the
fact that the fact that there are
computers governing uh Bitcoin is not a
scary thing is actually a positive thing
as as I think that since there is no
mother nature that as with gold you have
Mother Nature you have the nature that
you know the you have a fixed amount of
or limited supply of gold in the soil
um and that is what people uh were used
to and are used to when they think to a
scarce asset the fact that computers are
are basically uh running Bitcoin
shouldn't you know shouldn't be scary
but is actually kind of scary or kind of
uh weird for many still and I think we
as an industry should do a better job or
should keep doing uh or improving the
job that we are doing in explaining and
and and holding people towards Bitcoin
now when we think inside of the
stablecoin market
um obviously dollars on a blockchain are
the most popular right as you mentioned
um but there are now multiple companies
or organizations who have created dollar
back stable coins and so the two most
popular being tether and usdc but
there's a plethora of others uh that
have come into the market and each one
has varying degrees of success when you
look at the market is it a winner take
all winner take most do you think it's
actually important to have multiple
stable coin you know dollar back stable
coin winners like how do you look at
almost competition for the dollar
backstable coin itself
yeah I think look
um I like to think the stable coin as an
industry I don't think and an industry
can exist with only one player and um
you can see how much this this uh the
stable coins are subject of discussion
among Regulators in in different parts
of the world if the stablecoin industry
would be made by a single player I mean
would it not be an industry and probably
you know
every realtor would have you know reason
to shut it down in a way right because
you know you if there is only one
company that can do it is could be a
weird thing right so you want to have
diversity you want to have like
um the ability of people to choose to
look at the options to look at the track
historical track record
and all these type of things I think in
in in being
um in many uh we are giving and
providing a good use case and could um
diverse case to Regulators to make them
understand that this is a growing
technology again if there was one single
company it wouldn't you know would be
feeling weird right so why why no one
else would would is doing this the very
same thing and um Monopoly is never
never good I think
um the what I also think is that um for
example uh tether usdta is not
onboarding us customers so there are um
I heard that uh well I think it's possum
news uh PayPal is is launching is uh US
dollar or has launch is US dollar uh
stable coin
um starting from the US
um you know you can argue a circle is is
focusing and or that is one of their
main focuses so the world is a big place
um that I think that are
um has uh an eye towards
um emerging markets and developing
countries so I like the fact that you
know diverse geographically I think
diverse in in in the way they are run in
the philosophy that that is behind the
scenes and and so on so actually it's a
good thing
now when you think about
um tether and kind of the uh adoption
that it has received uh one of the big
questions that's always been around uh
treasury management and then also
regulation and and sometimes those two
things are related other times those two
things are completely separate right if
you were to almost think of it as a
business right you've got some people
who are dedicated to doing treasury
management do it as well as possible and
you've got other people who are worried
about regulation and being compliant and
stuff like that and so how do you all
think about uh treasury management maybe
as just like part of the internal
business and what you guys do and then
how does that relate into any of the
regulatory either inquiries or oversight
that you all are subjected to
that's a great question right so I'm I'm
in the face of tether for uh quite
enough a few years and um
the I think one of the best
um things that happened in the last two
years is um trial by fire right
um it's easy to say well you know
um what's going on behind the scenes and
um you know are you doing this are you
doing that right so and of course I I go
on and I I can't go on shows and explain
yes we are doing these type of things we
are we are extremely serious in Risk
Management we have a team we have uh
extremely professional people that are
day and night are monitoring the markets
aren't trying to understand
microeconomics
um they are they are you know I'm among
the best people that someone would could
aim for their company when it comes to
treasury management and risk management
I mean I feel so lucky to have to work
with this team yet
there is an interesting aspect that you
know talking about 2022 and 2023
um with starting with Tara Luna
um uh also tether became under attack
um you know classic father campaigns
um and uh that approved in in May 2022
it was able to redeem seven billion
dollars in between 48 hours 20 plus
billion dollars in 20 days
um a good Testament of you know the
solidity of tether it's related to Banks
right when we think that the seven
billion dollars were 10 of the reserves
and 20 billion dollars were plus where
25 of the reserves I mean it's then you
start asking or looking around at the
banks that you know and and see and ask
yourself would the banks be able to
survive to that type of scenario the
answer is no right in 2008 there was a
bank called Washington Mutual went
bankrupt for 10 of their of of
um of um Redemption of their their
Reserves
in 2023 we had Silicon Valley Bank
um we had uh sorry Silicon Valley Banks
they ensure Silver Gate all were shut
down for improper
um management uh of uh or uh too much
risk in in their portfolio uh to from my
understanding and um it's interesting
that one of our main competitors
actually was I had a lot of cash
uninsured cash on one of those Banks and
so
um what we did at tatter we always
thought that the bank the banks has
partners for sure for that because
tether is a usdt is a centralized stable
coin so it means that it's using
uh um it's using blockchains as a
transport layer but the issue is
centralized and so hence um as a
centralized stablecoin has to use the
use the banking system but uh using the
banking system doesn't mean trusting
blindly the banking system means that uh
the most important aspect of our life
better is protecting the portfolio and
when you want to protect the portfolio I
mean the obvious question is where
stablecoin doesn't put you know 82
billion dollars in cash in the bank
right you you guys should have 82
billion dollars in cash in the bank well
there is no bank that allows you to to
do that the these this cash would stay
in the balance sheet of the bank
and the case and the most important
thing is that in the case of a
bankruptcy this cash will be dragged
into the bankruptcy proceeding
instead if you use um USD bills if you
use
um that are basically Securities
um if you use
um reverse repos and so on if there is
any issue with the bank you know these
assets are returned to the owner and so
that would be in our case return to
tether even in the worst case scenario
so and and that I think that is the I
think some of our competitors found this
the hard way right they kept uninsured
cash in the bank it ended up in the in
the balance sheet of the bank and when
the blank Bank blew up they had they
needed the FDIC to save the bank for the
first time in history they have to save
the bank and provide all the Capital to
fill the hole otherwise there would be a
massive issue on such stable coins and
so these are the things that uh believe
it or not our team is is in insanely
focused on and you know we we're not
fine found in in that mistake we um we
we we were you know we I would say uh
being Italians with male problems like
one miles away probably you know uh so
um but um really
um I'm I'm really proud of of the work
that we have been doing there um um in
in this extremely turbulent period
now FDIC insurance is really interesting
in this scenario because basically what
you're highlighting is there's FDIC
Insurance up to the 250 000 limit and so
obviously that gives the average
consumer uh some degree of peace of mind
uh FDIC Insurance obviously wouldn't
save a business or an individual with
more than that unless they step in with
Extreme Measures as they did and so one
of the questions that people always ask
me is you know will tether get FDIC
insurance and what you're really
highlighting here is that FDIC insurance
doesn't really mean anything for tether
because there's so much money that
either you would have to put the money
cash in a bank you may have too much for
one single Bank to do that and so
actually the thing that guarantees or at
least increases the probability of uh
people getting the money back right the
the kind of the reserves is the T bills
are a much better solution for that than
having to rely on FDIC Insurance am I
understanding that correctly
um yes I mean the the fact that FDIC
decided to save um uh Silicon Valley
Bank was one maybe one in lifetime in
that event right so
um till like I think uh the issue
happened on a Thursday and until Sunday
no one knew if that would happen I mean
it never happened so you know it could
have happened or it could not so uh for
a stable coin relying on uh on um uh
Insurance on on on the bank balance
sheet is is not an option the um the
option the solution for a stable coin
issue is to use
um short-term U.S territory bills
and also products like Solutions like
overnight reverse repos fully
collateralized in USD bills so that you
need to
um to redeem 10 billion dollars
overnight you have the liquidity no
problems right so that is the type of um
information that is the type of
knowledge that we accrued over time and
makes uh me myself our team confident
and you know we proved
um it's we we were really tried uh by
higher in in being subject to Fat
Redemption I think the in one single we
process one single Redemption was 700
million dollar One Singular attention so
I think it it speaks highly about uh you
know we our our procedures
so one of the big pieces here is when
you're putting the money into T bills
even if they're short-term t-bills uh
you can generate a lot of Revenue and in
q1 tether reported I think it was like
almost 1.5 billion dollars of net profit
uh in Q2 I think the number ended up
being somewhere around 850 million
dollars and so let's put it at you know
two to two and a half billion dollars of
profit in the first half of this year is
that something that uh you think is just
solely tied to interest rates and we're
in a high interest rate environment so
that's good for tether and when those
rates come down we should expect profit
to come down or there are other things
that you all can do from a treasury
management standpoint that one continue
to secure the treasury reserves but also
two can help to drive uh revenue and
profit for the business even if rates
were to come down in the future
well um first of all uh tether is
actually everyone knows better for for
the stable coin usdt right so but the
the reality of things is that tether is
expanding quickly in different areas
um so
um the roll of tether is to ensure that
the stablecoin is secure it has
um is in this moment we have uh the the
market cap of theater is 83 billion
dollars and the tether has more than 3.3
billion dollars in additional reserves
um accrued in the in the last few
quarters
and this quarter will be a good quarter
again and and so on and so forth right
as you said we are living in a high
interest rate uh period And so
um we expect that to continue a little
bit but not forever right um um and uh
also means that if this the high
interest rate
um period would continue for a long time
that would be not good for the global
economy right you would expect
eventually to calm down a little bit so
the stable coin I think the
profitability of the stable coin will go
down I must say that um tether maintain
always a lean team uh for
um even when interest rates were at uh
um were really low or you know at some
point I think that it was making around
15 basis points
um on to 20 business points on average
on each portfolio yet
um that there was um was profitable one
one of the other things that tether has
been doing compared to the other stable
coins and that is actually one of the
things that Regulators
are interested in and and are happy with
is the fact that tether has
um the fact that tether has 10 business
points issuance and Redemption fees
allow tether to remain profitable tatter
usdt to remain profitable only also
sorry in doing
um low interest rate periods and so
tether is this stable coin Behemoth
um the profitability goes up and down
based on interest rates the good thing
is that with the capital that we are
accruing the vast majority is capped at
the um to further back uh the stable
coin right now it's around 104
[Music]
um
the um so four percent of over
collateralization and but with part of
the profit status is expanding different
business lines we are we started working
in energy production and Bitcoin mining
we launched
um
in partnership with hole punch
um and communication peer-to-peer
communication platform uh that uh
um that developed heat as a peer-to-peer
uh video conferencing and video call and
audio and chart tool we are really
excited about that a new version of
Keith mobile will come in next two three
weeks will be insanely better will be
much more scalable uh super secure feel
and so on so
um and we are working on other products
and so I think tether is a company will
grow its profitability over time the
stable coin part will be maybe in
certain periods extremely profitable in
other periods less profitable but it's
okay right so
um when we launched tether we we
couldn't we couldn't believe
um this uh this fast growth anyway
yeah is it something where you would
ever consider taking the company public
or kind of going a more traditional path
given you know I'm assuming investors
knock on the door all the time when you
are reporting two billion dollars worth
of profits in the first half of a year
uh that's something where whether
they're private investors or public
investors they want to get exposure to
profits of that size how have you
thought about the maturation of tether
you know kind of the the holding company
if you will as a business and what are
the plans there
so we we discussed a few times about the
opportunity I mean we are not shutting
the door uh to potentially bring in that
are public but I must say that um you
know I'm sorry about that but I'm always
going back to the my Italian roots and
John Carlo my business partner Roots you
know we come from uh Italy right and
there is a huge company called Ferrero
the one that makes Nutella that is a
private company I mean the business is
driving
um they're doing great and they are not
interested to bring the company public I
think if you love what I love what
you're doing if you are excited if you
have long-term plans I mean if you are
um an investor or the company but you
you know you you really are married to
to that uh to to that Vision I think
it's kind of hard to bring it public
that's that's at least our feeling this
moment
yes that um that makes sense uh as part
of the reserves another question that um
I get is obviously having the T bills
and kind of what I'll consider other
traditional safe uh Capital allocation
uh that any large institution would
pursue uh make sense but what about
putting things like Bitcoin as part of
the treasury reserves and you know have
you guys done that is that something
that you think is beneficial or
potentially you know kind of violates
the treasury management strategy that
you guys have in place right now
it's a great question
um uh it's the information that is
publicly available better in its
portfolio has around 1.5 billion in
Bitcoin
um given that tether has more than 3.3
billion in excess uh Equity that is you
know company profits non-distributed if
even if Bitcoin would go to zero
um data would still have more money than
you know all the total issued tokens
um also tether holds
um uh gold as part of its reserves
um we think that the world is extremely
unpredictable and that our users should
be protected from edge cases
um what we are looking at is that
European Banks but I was reading that
also probably in the US is even the
banks are allowed to put up to five
percent of the capital in in Bitcoin
and the bank balance sheet in Bitcoin so
we have our ratio is around 1.5 percent
on on the Bitcoin side and again
um it's smaller than our
um company access Equity but yeah we are
thinking about you know with really uh
small portions of the portfolio uh we
are thinking about uh you know some
small diversification to give a little
bit of counterbalance to the enormous
exposure that we have with the USD bills
uh we made a calculation right now I
think
um with um give or take last last
numbers is around 72.5 billion in USD
bills that would put tether to be the
set 20 if that was a country it would
put better to be the 22nd chance during
the world for how many tbls um
um we have in in our reserves and uh
um so that that is uh of course a big
number
um and uh we are of course excited uh we
we couldn't not believe that to be in
the situation but also you makes you
think that at some point you have you
need a little bit of diversification
um and I think our risk management over
time proved to be
um correct in in its strategy yeah that
makes sense
um obviously uh people always want to
talk about Audits and and uh it's this
weird thing where uh you all are doing
public uh kind of uh uh maybe
transparent view of what's in the uh
reserves then there is like a CPA or an
actual auditor type thing there's also
attestations talk a little bit about
like what have you guys done in the past
and then how are you all thinking about
now uh you know giving as much
information to people who hold tether as
to where you know the funds are in the
reserves
yeah sure so
um in this moment
um 2023 the the
um industry standard the stable industry
standard is the attestation attestations
are not third party at the stations
attestations are not
um audits but they are also
um a good instrument to evaluate the
composition of the reserves a stable
coin that doesn't mean that the theater
is not interested
um to perform a full audit uh actually
you know in the past we we went public
saying that we were working on audit and
uh it is taken a long time for different
reasons so you know
um initially uh definitely adverse media
didn't help I think that in the last few
years uh tether made wonderful progress
in in providing transparency providing
um reassurance we have seen this Black
Swan events that almost kill our
competitors killed good parts of the
crypto industry they didn't touch tether
at all given you know it's it's good
risk management and stability
nevertheless uh we are after FTX
um the uh you you cannot believe how
many Auditors are you know scared about
uh you know touching the crypto industry
with a 10 football some of them are not
taking on new
um contracts for for uh for all for
auditing and um if you if you look at
the big four auditing firms uh my
understanding is that there was a public
message uh from someone notable in the
Congress that suggested that Auditors
should not take new customers new crypto
customers as as customers and so you
know I
and I he I to me it's very important to
um to express the fact that tether wants
always to improve uh its transparency
has done a tremendous job in doing that
it was the first stable coin to provide
the breakdown of reserves
um if you look at the attestation of
tether if you look at the notes that um
BDO that is a top five uh the top fifth
uh Auditor in the world
um is doing these attestations the the
process the the level of um of details
that they go through
um for for the attestation is is really
high is almost comparable to an audit
and if you look at the other
attestations I mean they are much lesser
like uh okay yeah we see that couple
numbers that's fine so you know also the
the our video is interested so is is
doing the attestation work but at the
same time wants to make sure that
everything is is proper and so they are
doing a really sorry more work in in in
in the for the station so uh I I think
in the future the future will still see
uh tether and is still we are actually
actually working towards an audit and uh
you know in the past we made the mistake
of uh of giving some deadlines that we
could not meet we are that didn't it
doesn't change our focus our commitment
so um I'm positive that and uh you know
that our team will continue in that
direction
that um that makes sense let's talk a
little bit in terms of
um uh tether's growth and many stable
coins growth but tether specifically uh
I think people look at and they're like
oh I think of the asset but there's
underlying technology to this asset and
one of the stories that I think is a
narrative violation is that tether on
Tron and tetheron binance smart chain
have become much more popular than
people realize until they look at the
data and part of that I think is people
want low-cost fast transactions but
there may be other reasons as well and
so how do you think about tether on
various blockchains and the popularity
of maybe some of the blockchains that
people wouldn't expect being the choice
for users around the world
well the this topic is um also pretty
recent in a way in a sense that um
unfortunately recently tether had to
announce the
um the commissioning of um omnilayer
that was the first uh let's say layer on
top Bitcoin that that are used to issue
usdt is uh is a bit I'm a bit sad uh
because of course
um that was our first love and uh also
was Bitcoin based
um nevertheless tether has um higher
commitment to ensuring that
if that are maintains the usage of a
blockchain it is because that blockchain
has a threshold of usage right you don't
want to support 100 blockchains and have
like uh you know 95 of them uh with
couple transactions per per day or per
month because that would uh supporting
blockchains add to the complexity of
management uh of tether from the
technological point of view and if there
is no actual reason it's not there is no
transfer volume and so on it's it
becomes more you know um uh you use less
complexity
and so
um tatter started from Omni and then
added ethereum and then other Tron
the uh the
the thing is that Tron as as you entered
has really low or had especially in the
past really low transaction fees if you
go in Africa if you go in South America
no one wants to touch
um ethereum with a 10-foot pole I mean
what you know transaction fees that
for a European person on ethereum that
are really high but in especially in
Emerging Markets developing countries
they are insanely high and so of course
now you have all these layer tools you
have arbit room you have optimism and so
on they're trying to be more efficient
they try to take down the cost of fees
but the reality is that Tron has been
super simple to integrate for many
um is basically a turnkey solution and
again
and we have also always to think about
um the
um the purpose so
if you want
money that will resist to the wrath of
God to an apocalypse that is Bitcoin but
tether is issued by centralized
insurance so blockchains are a transport
layer for teller right so they are
um a secondary market and a transport
layer and so on so in the end even if
one transportation is more decentralized
than another
it's cool it matters but matters still a
certain extent right eventually there is
still the same issue behind all the
implementations and so people just
choose it's a commodity right for for
tether for usdt apple blockchain and so
people will choose the one that will
make them save more money
that makes sense when you think about
tether
um and its impact in the crypto Market
what would happen if tether went away
like one of the things that I always
think about is just whether it was
regulatory uh kind of action whether it
was some sort of technological failure
whether it was you guys just say hey
this was fun we're gonna shut it all
down and you know go home uh it could be
a whole bunch of different reasons some
of them could be you know decisions you
guys make some of them could be external
things but is it something where now
tether has become almost you know like
it's too big to fail within the kind of
Bitcoin and crypto Market or do you
think that uh like many things in the
industry you know things come and go and
and if tether for some reason was to go
away uh tomorrow the industry would
still be okay
look I think that uh if uh
um data would go away would be you know
I like to think that uh eventually the
world will move towards
um and I I believe in the hyper
bitcoinization so you know if uh if the
world will go towards uh uh you know
more and more adoption of Bitcoin I
think it's fine for teller to
um to to decrease and and uh to to
potentially subtitle usdt to decrease
and then go away there are the products
like XLT or other things that we are
doing right so
we are I mean we are not that uh the
type of guys and saying well we have to
do everything that we can to make sure
that uh you know tether will be used in
from year to the next two thousand years
that doesn't make any sense for us right
so if the world doesn't need any more
stable current technology that's fine
means that the word is evolving uh the
word is to going towards other
directions and so I think that uh tether
will always try to innovate and create a
cool stuff you know communication energy
Bitcoin mining all kind of things and
tatter just want to be at service of the
industry if there is no need for tether
um usdt in the future I think will be
organ and an organic Decline and I don't
think Bitcoin will be affected they
probably if uh if uh that will
um that will happen when more and more
people will finally understand Bitcoin
that makes sense another thing that's
interesting about stable coins today is
uh stable coins seem to have risen in
popularity mainly because uh Banks and
large uh central banks or large
financial institutions haven't embraced
blockchain Technologies they've talked
about it there's been research uh there
has been maybe some experimentation But
ultimately the rise of stable coins and
especially the profits that you all are
driving internally Etc is going to get
the attention of these organizations and
so you mentioned earlier PayPal is now
launching kind of a dollar back stable
coin uh you would think that other
organizations are going to follow suit
and whether they actually launch a
stable coin or maybe they just become
friendlier to stable coins in kind of
the crypto industry what is the impact
on the existing stable coins is it
something where more people being
involved in whether it's competition or
friendliness than that right you know
all boats rise together or do you think
actually there's a world where the big
Banks could come in and use regulatory
capture or something else to potentially
get a leg up on and steal market share
from whether it's tether you usdc or
others
so that's
um that's a great question and in a way
it's like playing 5D chess game right so
um I the way I think to it is that
um
there are different models right there
are the cbcs so Central Bank digital
currencies
there are
um Banks not necessarily central banks
like the the
super big banks in the world that could
um uh work together to create their own
stable coins I mean in this moment
I'm hearing from a lot of small banks
that want to create their own stable
coin but I don't believe that is the a
good solution or it's a solution that
will last or will be practical imagine
that you have 50 banks that are doing
their own US dollar stable coin I mean
what
is the exchange rate one to one you know
which transfer layer where there will be
curve pools or or like whatever in order
to exchange them I mean it's going to be
from a user experience not not much from
the financial side but the user
experience would be a mess right so in
the end people will always pivot for one
or two solution three four Solutions but
not 50. right so then um so there is the
layer of small banks that trying they're
trying to capture the flag before the
big banks are are getting there because
the small Banks probably will can have
the ability to move faster
then um the big Banks could all sit
together and work towards the solution
that is shared right because if they
don't share solution they will fight
each other in in eternity and that will
not work either because you know if I'm
pretty sure that every big bank would
like to have dominance on on
um a stable coin but yet if uh that
would that is a factor that probably is
in common with all the big Banks and so
they will still end up in finding each
other and so the only solution is that
they seat all together at least trying
to create the Monopoly and then
um issue a stable coin that they all
recognize that could actually work and
that could be one of the most probable
outcomes
um then there is um
and and then there is the cbdcs so
Central Bank
um digital currencies I think that
especially in the western world uh that
is a little bit trickier too for a
government to issue a CBC we are seeing
in the U.S uh people in Congress fight
against the concept of a CBC there are a
ton of issues from the or valian future
to the fact that cbdc's would replace
cash but cash doesn't pay any positive
interest or
um you know negative interest and the
issue is that of course cash is still
subject to inflation that is in a way is
negative interest but uh
um nevertheless uh imagine what happens
if tomorrow the us would have a cbdc and
they decide to put negative interest on
on the on the cbtc I think there will be
a Revolt in in arrived in the country so
it's really difficult for from a central
bank to have to really play this with uh
you know with understanding all the
variables and what the facility would it
be successful where are all the banks go
going I mean they will all the
transactional fees of the banks will
will completely be wiped out and many
banks could go Belly Up and ton of
people in the streets without jobs so
it's really difficult for a central bank
to decide so
then we go back to Big Banks deciding
um to to create a monopoly
um uh token a stable coin but also you
know the I think is important
um the the that uh people uh like also
the um the ability to to to move money
um through blockchains and and jump
across Bridges and so on so if um if
these big Banks um would not allow this
Factor then uh probably
um they their product will be less used
in the merchant markets or in the more
sophisticated tech industry and so on
and so forth so I think is a fairly
unpredictable I think that there is
still
um uh in in great position to um to keep
innovating this sector and keep moving
uh faster than the others especially
when it comes to Banks
my last question for you is about tether
the business itself how big is it is it
a distributed company how do you guys
operate the business internal I think
people are fascinated with just the
scale of how quickly this has grown over
nine years and you're coming up on the
19 year uh ninth year anniversary now
how do you think about it from just a
pure entrepreneurship standpoint and you
know what what does the employee size
look like and how do you manage it on a
day-to-day basis
so feather
um uh personal size is around 60 people
now
um that could make it the most
profitable company per per capital in
the world I guess but uh nevertheless
um we have been hiring a lot in the last
um uh two years and we keep we are going
to keep higher
um um in in next um in next next several
months and because we are expanding the
business lines we are expanding the
products both on the staplecoin side we
have a couple of I think brilliant ideas
that time I kind of share about them I'm
super excited about them and uh and also
we are expanding in other areas like
energy production Bitcoin mining
communication and so on so they grow the
size of of tether will be
um of the Personnel will increase quite
fast
um also we are working on educational
projects you know across um you know
um on um you know not not related to
crypto but also I'm really we aren't we
are big Believers on the fact that the
future the
um informatization of of education is is
one of the key points of the growth of
humanity in the in the future and so we
are investing also on that part so
um right now you can imagine that uh
among these um you know 60 plus uh
people uh most of them are basically
Finance right so uh but they will they
will move we will move away well no more
we will move towards a more diverse
um
um or more
um uh complex organization in the next
months we have big announcements coming
up coming up
awesome well I appreciate you taking the
time to do this where can we send people
to find you on the internet or learn
more about tether
um they can follow uh tether at tether
underscore Teo on Twitter or at Paulo
Arduino
um on Twitter as well
awesome Paolo thank you so much for
taking the time to do it we'll
definitely do it again in the future
thank you very much Anthony